[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
anguille assez cette longue et plate
bande de terre qui s'étale et ses tirs
face à saint martin on y accède
principalement par des navettes
maritimes plus de 85 % des visiteurs
passent par boeing paint le port
d'entrée de lille qui ressemblait à cela
avant jorma mais le paysage a bien
changé depuis le cyclone qui a frappé
durement aussi ce territoire attachés à
la couronne britannique
à première vue ça ne se voit pas car on
a fait place nette
les bâtiments en ruines ont été
rapidement rasé on a tout fait pour
effacer au plus vite les stigmates du
cyclone sauver les apparences en ce
début de haute saison touristique
c'est toujours très important de
nettoyer rapidement lille parce que le
tourisme est notre principale industrie
si le tourisme chute c'est l'économie de
l'île qui peut s'effondrer donc c'est
vraiment très important de veiller à ce
que les touristes puissent continuer à
venir et visiter l'île l'an dernier nous
avons eu environ 75 mille visiteurs on
espère un autre record cette année mais
bien sur le dernier trimestre sera
gravement affectés par le cyclone
irma nous attendons à voir une réduction
significative de la fréquentation entre
maintenant et l'année prochaine parce
que c'est vrai que nous avons été
durement frappée par le cyclone
et les choses ne sont pas parfaites et
impeccable comme à l'accoutumée
[Musique]
ici c'était le royaume de banksy bank's
la star anglaise du reggae
[Musique]
sa résidence perché au dessus d'une
plage avec vue sur saint martin a subi
la fureur dire en masse
c'est ici que j'étais devant le cyclone
l'artiste de 64 ans s'en est sorti
vivant
[Musique]
mais comme le titre de son premier
succès enregistré il ya 42 ans le prince
des ténèbres est bel et bien passée par
la philosophe micky banks porte sa croix
il tenait ici un bar restaurant de plage
très populaire classe et même comme l'un
des meilleurs du monde par les revues
spécialisées et à wall street
ici il y avait le bar de plage ici là le
bar de plage
il est parti à la mer voici l'entrée
précisé sur ce site rustique mais
légendaire banking jouer sa musique
depuis 1994 il accueilli 6 quantité
d'artistes nés rita marley burning spear
buju banton et bien d'autres sont montés
sur la scène de son festival annuel
les soirs de pleine lune
bon ce plh un grand concert une fois
leur mars
voici la scène à celle là bas si c'est
l'espace des personnalités la 28e
édition du monde flash est prévu le 28
mars poche pour bangui banks le show va
continuer si l'hôtellerie de lille se
remet d'aplomb d'ici là gênés 3 je
nettoie et je reconstruis et vous allez
jouer à nouveau et je jouerai encore
j'ai déjà vécu plusieurs cyclones ce
doigt quand luis wague en ligne omar
j'ai eu des problèmes
vous savez c'est une plage comme celle
ci crée vulnérables vous êtes heureuse
si vous avez cinq années sans problème
jour des ennuis donc dans votre tête
vous gardez les doigts croisés et cette
année ne sera pas une saison touristique
normal je pense qu'il y a trop pas faire
la saison touristique démarre novembre
c'est trop tôt dans cinq ou six mois
nous serons prêts ou du moins à ses
prêts mais vous savez les arbres doivent
repartir
il n'y a pas de paradis sans les
cocotiers ils prennent longtemps
si les cocotiers malmené pariant maçons
des plumes et des parasols des transats
ont refait leur apparition au nord-est
de l'île mais il reste prier et
désespérément vie les touristes ne sont
pas encore revenus sur les plages comme
celle de shaw lever régulièrement classé
parmi les plus belles du monde ça se
voit guère ce qu'enfin c'est ce que les
clients viennent chercher saab soleil et
merde il agréable chaises longues et une
boisson fraîche
c'est ce que les gens viennent chercher
ici ici le sable est une matière
précieuse
si laure d'anguilla le pilier de
l'économie touristique
du coup il est bichonné par les employés
de cet hôtel
ils remettent en place le sable qui
avaient envahi les abords de la piscine
un grand nettoyage accompagné d'une
rénovation complète le cadre la déco
doivent être parfaits le confort et les
services offerts sur la plage occupe ici
une grande importance tout le monde
travaille donc d'arrache-pied pour être
dans les temps tous les dommages causés
par le cyclone doivent être effacés
avant le 17 novembre
c'est la date fixée pour la réouverture
de cet hôtel
les samoans internet y est voici
certains des guerres que nous avons eues
durant le cycle nous avons perdu sept de
nos baies vitrées et nous avons perdu
deux éléments sous la toiture du
bâtiment principal de l'hôtel
l'un a déjà été remplacé celui là le
sera très bientôt
et second à voici l'une des chambres qui
a été endommagé durant le passage de
cyclone irma son avance par ici vous
voyez que nous avons perdu toute la bvmt
la fenêtre
même au coeur de la cité il faut aller
de l'avant et ici nous essayons
d'avancer
nous essayons d'avancer en guinée a
choisi d'être un repère pour vacanciers
fortunés les hôtels et villas haut de
gamme ont poussé sur les plages assurant
à lille une réputation de destination de
luxe ici toutes les chambres ont vue sur
mer la directrice tient à nous montrer
qu'elles sont opérationnels pour la
saison d'autant que l'électricité a été
rétablie récemment actuellement nous
sommes dans une suite avec deux chambres
ça c'est l'une des chambres à coucher la
salle de bains et par là nous pouvons
aller dans le coin salon qui a une vue
panoramique sur l'océan
ici c'est une autre chambre avec aussi
une belle salle de bain nous allons
commencer avec des réservations plutôt
limité nous commençons avec environ 30 %
d'occupation
parce que nous avons perdu nos
réservations avec le cyclone
si tu es aussi sur la plage de sol b cet
établissement subit également le
contrecoup d'irma selon la propriétaire
à cette période de l'année tous ces
hébergements sont occupés des
appartements villas avec cuisine toute
équipée salle à manger salon et chambre
à coucher type d'hébergement très
apprécié par sa clientèle américaine et
italienne notamment pour la proximité de
la mer mais depuis le cyclone
les annulations sanchez à la réception
son calendrier de réservations
s'éclaircit de jour en jour ce tableau
normalement c'est notre tableau de
réservation est normalement à cette
période de l'année nous sommes vraiment
complet mais depuis le cyclone et depuis
que les compagnies ont arrêté leur vol
sur saint martin nous avons 80 %
d'annulations foncière nos allons
réellement ouvrir cette semaine nous
avons quelques clients fidèles qui doit
venir
mais ce que l'on voit en bleu c'est du
personnel humanitaire qui est hissé
jusqu'au mois de novembre
et vous voyez pour noël nous avons
beaucoup de chambres vides alors qu'on
devrait normalement être complet cette
structure a été l'une des toutes
premières à rouvrir sur l'île moins
d'une semaine après le passage des armes
à cette anglaise tombée amoureuse
d'anguilla s'y plier en quatre pour
accueillir le personnel humanitaire
s'efforcer d'avoir nos chambres
pérationnel parce que nous avons d'abord
reçu dix sept docteurs et infirmières
venues des îles caïmans nous avons eu
des gens de la chasse américaine des
secours et d'autres organismes comme
l'unicef et sont tous venus ici nous
avons commencé le 12 septembre avec eux
même s'il n'y avait pas d'eau courante
nous avons un groupe électrogène nous le
faisions fonctionnel
pour remettre le couvert cette saison il
faudra patienter les meilleures tables
de l'île ont été emportées par le vent
et la houle d'irma c'est le cas de ce
restaurant qui attirer des touristes
fortune les grands hôtels durement
frappé aussi par yamaha ont fermé ils
n'ouvriront pas avant avril 2018 comme
ce cinq étoiles
sur la plage de mythes b autres lieux
emblématiques d'anguilla souvent
fréquentée par les stars et célébrités
on vit du tourisme de luxe la zone
concentre tout plein de palaces comme
man wan a affirmé aussi jusqu'à l'an
prochain cet hôtel un quatre étoiles
tente 8 se remettent d'un plan pour la
haute saison
le grand nettoyage a déjà eu lieu leurs
rites aux réparations et à la rénovation
le jeune directeur met le paquet pour
repartir de plus belle
il montre aux responsables de
l'association des hôteliers de l'île ses
travaux en cours nous travaillons
actuellement sur toutes les portes et
fenêtres on les nettoie
nous avons beaucoup de travail pour être
l'être en même temps c'est une
opportunité
nous avons hâte de reconstruire nous
sommes sur ce chemin
il ya des ouvriers ici tous les jours et
nous allons ouvrir en décembre
nous n'avons pas d'électricité mais à ce
stade nous avons un groupe électrogène
pour couvrir l'ensemble de la propriété
donc nous avons pu avoir du courant pour
assurer les réservations mais le
principal problème c'est l'accès aux
matériaux à la main d'oeuvre
l'organisation des hôtels restaurants de
l'île tente de convaincre ses adhérentes
se relancer au plus vite
ici le tourisme est le pilier de
l'économie toute la population est
dépendante de ce secteur vital
nous avons 13 milles entre 13000 et
quatorze mille habitants sur l'île
la main d'oeuvre est d'à peu près 8000
et le nombre d'emplois générés par le
tourisme est d'environ 5000
c'est un nombre très élevé car cela
représente quelque chose comme 60 à 70 %
de la main-d'oeuvre est fausse
ce nombre est si élevé qu'il est
essentiel de s'assurer que nous soyons
de retour et opérationnels car les faits
seraient dévastateurs si vous avez
quatre à cinq mille personnes au chômage
x fighters vous pouvez imaginer quelle
catastrophe ce serait pour le pays
avec la fermeture de tous les grands
hôtels l'heure n'est pas à l'embellie
irma a porté un coup fatal aux finances
publiques
les recettes touristiques se sont
effondrés comme de nombreuses églises de
l'île au sérieux casse-tête pour le
gouvernement
pour terminer l'année on prévoit d'ores
et déjà un déficit budgétaire de 15
millions d'euros et de graves
répercussions sociales les taxes de
séjour et de douane représente 300 % de
nos revenus globaux en conséquence dès
que le secteur touristique est en
difficulté veut dire que les recettes
issues de ce secteur sensible ont du mal
à rentrer à sauver mais nous avons
besoin d'avoir un grand hôtel ouvert et
en état de marche qu'au que le travail
puisse réellement reprendre la situation
actuelle des répercussions sur 2000
travailleurs de ce secteur
ils sont licenciés au chômage partiel
nous n'avons pas d'allocation chômage
pour quelques et sans emploi il est
vraiment sans heureusement si le cas de
cette femme depuis le cyclone elle vit
sur la corde raide
la lessive le repassage elle connaît
c'est son quotidien son métier elle
travaillait à la blanchisserie de grands
hôtels de l'île je suis sans emploi
depuis le cyclone
j'étais en vacances juste avant et après
le passage du cyclone
il n'y a plus de travail pour s'occuper
bernadine fait sa grande lessive
mais cette femme de 62 ans est en plein
désarroi et le sexe on hôtels ne
rouvrira ses portes que dans un an une
longue très longue période à se débattre
sans argent pourquoi vous pleurez
le truc que nous les gens comme ma mère
toute leur vie ils l'ont passé à
travailler travailler travailler c'est
le pire des moments
nous lui apportons à manger la croix
rouge du cias plein de gens
voici sans dire warne le principal port
de l'île c'est aussi un village de
pêcheurs très populaire le lieu est
habituellement très fréquentés aussi
bien par les touristes que les anguilles
sur la plage les petits commerces se
sont plus ou moins reconstitués meilleur
mais a laissé de profondes cicatrices
même s'il s'en dit waouh montre semblant
de normalité
quatre jours après le cyclone il ya eu
des équipements lourds des pelleteuses
ici et aussi les gens qui vivent dans le
quartier ils ont participé en
rassemblant les débits et la machine qui
était juste ici avec les camions et tout
ça ce que le gouvernement fournit les
camions ils ont tout enlever rapidement
pourquoi c'est important
oui parce qu'ici c'est très important
c'est l'un des hauts lieux touristiques
comme vous le voyez nous avons beaucoup
de restaurants dans la zone c'est très
important pour nous de garder cet
endroit propre et organiser aussi vite
que possible
daron tient ce petit commerce sur la
plage où il écoule une partie de sa
pêche
il est plongeur de l'ambient
excursionnistes accessoirement des
activités heures pour au point mort à
cause de ces embarcations endommagé
d'une demande en chute libre mais
surtout à cause de l'absence
d'électricité depuis plus de deux mois
après le cyclone et en main le problème
essentiel l électricité pour la
nourriture ce n'est pas un problème et
l'électricité c'est le grand souci car
elle n'arrive pas ici pour pêcher parce
que nous avons besoin de glace au moins
en tant que plongeur j'ai besoin de
l'électricité pour alimenter mans
compresseur et remplir des bouteilles
avec rma tout le réseau de distribution
électrique de l'île est littéralement
tombé la centrale est opérationnel mais
la plupart des lignes électriques sont à
refaire
des kilomètres de câbles endommagés
jonchent les routes de l'île
le travail de restauration a commencé
mais la compagnie locale d'électricité
manque de main d'oeuvre spécialisée
notamment ceux que l'on appelle les
lignards ces électriciens qui grimpe les
poteaux et jongle avec les câbles
électriques des commandos de la lumière
sont venus de plusieurs villes de la
région ont prêté main forte mais cela
reste encore très insuffisant le
calendrier initial prévoit un
rétablissement complet en février ou
mars 2018
mais la saison touristique qui démarre
mais sous tension les responsables
d'anglais au siège de la compagnie
d'électricité
il nous montre cette carte qui permet de
visualiser les progrès des travaux tout
ce qui est en rouge et déjà réalimentés
en courant c'est près de 40 % du réseau
l'essonne en orange sont les zones en
chantier les zones en bleu sont les
zones qui seront en chantier dans les
prochains jours l'ouest de l'île où se
concentre l'essentiel des hôtels est
encore dans le noir
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'accélérer
les travaux et de réalimenter tout le
monde pour noël vous savez nous avons
des pressions à l'est et à l'ouest
bien sûr il ya un intérêt particulier
parce que la partie ouest de l'île est
notre ceinture touristique c'est là que
nous avons bon nombre de grands hôtels
season le barrio annales ces mêmes
hôtels ont aussi besoin de temps pour se
reconstruire ma travaillons donc avec
leur calendrier l'on va vite mais aussi
pour tout le pays
les hôtels peuvent fonctionner
efficacement les touristes n'ont pas
besoin d'entendre de sentir les fumées
de gazole c'est un découragement pour le
secteur touristique
économiquement cela a des répercussions
sur l'emploi et sur le développement du
pays
dans les zones encore privés
d'électricité le bourdonnement continu
des groupes électrogènes accompagne les
clients des rares restaurants ouverts la
nuit
celui ci a été l'un des premiers à
rouvrir après le cyclone
une initiative appréciée de la
population locale l'établissement est
tenu par un français installé sur l'île
depuis 18 ans ce boulanger de formation
s'il reconverti à la cuisine dans ses
assiettes des plats simples proposé au
jour le jour car sans réfrigérateur
impossible de stocker et de conserver
des aliments
angers d'essence les jours après faut
pas casser le groupe parce que ça c'est
le deuxième le premier on m'a mal
renseigné au niveau de l'huile pour le
moteur donc eh ben j'ai serré le moteur
donc j'ai dû en acheter un autre
va vous paraître aux jeunes comme ça
c'est 1500 $ quand cette année ça va
être un niveau touristique franchement
ça va être moins deux mois après le
passage du cyclone y remet à cette vidéo
a circulé sur les réseaux sociaux avec
un message anguilles à est prête à
accueillir les touristes
[Musique]
ce sont les services du gouverneur de
l'île qui ont publié cette vidéo sur ce
territoire britannique d'outre-mer team
fourier le représentant du royaume uni
lille a une autonomie interne mais sous
contrôle britannique
le gouverneur s'occupe de la défense
comme de la sécurité intérieure
visiblement il assure aussi la promotion
touristique fait que la saison
touristique démarre en novembre que les
banques soient ouvertes que les stations
service fonctionne bien que les
supermarchés soient remplies que toutes
les choses nécessaires soient en place
pour la saison touristique
je pense qu envoyer ce message nous
sommes opérationnels et la bonne chose à
faire parce que c'est la vérité
nommé à ce poste quelques jours avant le
cyclone ou l'actuel gouverneur se démène
pour reconstruire lille au niveau de son
image pour l'aide financière le
gouvernement britannique rochina mettre
la main à la poche
une dizaine de millions d'euros dépensés
à ce jour pour venir en aide à sa
dépendance d'outre-mer le gouverneur
multiplie aussi les démarches pour le
rétablissement de l'électricité dit
renfort canadiens sont attendus ils
l'annoncent à ce patron d'un des plus
grands complexes hôteliers de l'île
fermée depuis hier au mas
le rif et le dernier fleuron de
l'hôtellerie anguilles ce cinq étoiles
fait partie d'un vaste complexe géré par
ce français
ici les dégâts d'irma sont importants et
nécessitent une fermeture prolongée
nous sommes situés face à saint martin
cet hôtel composé aussi de villa les
pieds dans l'eau est essentiellement
fréquenté par une clientèle américanisé
l'évaluation des dommages causés par
jorma donne le vertige
le coût des dégâts c'est entre 20 et 30
millions de dollars en la saison sera un
petit peu difficile de la sauver
entièrement mai
nous on planifie de nouveaux plafonds
planifiant de d'ouvrir l'hôtel au rif au
mois d'avril 2018
et puis ensuite l'autre tel cuisine art
qui a été encore plus plus touché que le
rif
on le verra au mois de novembre 2018 la
propriété englobe cette autre hôtel le
cuisine art à l'architecturé entrée
méditerranée l'hôtel en lui-même mais
qu'en serait de 2,2 de 10 villes à
chaque villa à 8 suites toutes les
villas sont en face à la mer et comme on
voit même deux mois après ça comment ça
ça commence à se reconstruire tous aller
avec avec tous les jardins qui commence
à vraiment devenir vert est bien ici au
grand soin apporté à l'environnement et
à la nourriture
le complexe possède plusieurs
restaurants gastronomiques emploie 300
personnes en haute saison et dispose de
sa propre usine de dessalement de l'eau
pour l'entretien du golfe et des jardins
car ici en cultivait tomates salades
concombres et autres légumes frais dans
des serres hydroponiques balayé par liam
c'est assez désolant de voir ça de com
de cette de cette manière mais si vous
revenez l'année prochaine vous allez
voir c'est extraordinaire comme comme
système est comme comme site qui fait
vraiment la magie de cet hôtel parce que
l'hôtel hôtel cuisine à c'est tout
l'aspect cuisine par le nom et enlever
tout autour de la cuisine et ça ça fait
partie de bien évidemment ça fait partie
de du succès de l'autre elle retour un
mix b où l'on compte bien dans les temps
pour sauver une partie de la saison
touristique
les artisans du bâtiment sont à la
manoeuvre ils ont du pain sur la planche
les carnets de commandes sont pleins et
les délais très serrés
huit semaines seulement pour refaire du
sol au plafond
le restaurant emblématique de cette
plage nous avons une date limite le 16
décembre pour livrer les travaux et que
ce soit opérationnel ce restaurant là l
un des principaux de lille un restaurant
très fréquenté très populaire donc c'est
vraiment important d'avoir cet endroit
ouvert parce que quand les touristes
viennent sur l'île ils réclament le
squat le touriste c'est vraiment tout
pour nous si nous n'ouvrons pas dans les
temps nous aurons des problèmes parce
que les anglais ne nous aide pas nous
sommes bloqués
mais notre relation avec eux est une
drôle de relation vous savez les anglais
ne nous aide pas vraiment financièrement
nous devons nous débrouiller par nous
mêmes
c'était bien quand nous avions eu lieu
auquel on pouvait s'appuyer sur l'europe
maintenant on est séparés dieu seul sait
ce qui va se passer maintenant
où la dame bannissez pas de bas du
tableau
[Musique]
banksy box ne se laisse pas abattre par
l'adversité et continue à jouer sa
musique dans les ruines de sa maison ont
été recouverts protéger de l'eau et a
survécu aux cyclones a survécu je suis
très content
face à saint martin bien calé dans son
hamac ce rescapés du cyclone yerma
cultive même lumeau nous avons toujours
laver c'est toujours la même vu un
exemple de résilience parmi d'autres sur
cette île habitué à rebondir après les
épreuves